Let's go next to Nick from Ohio. Nick from
Ohio. What's going on, David? Can you hear
me? I can hear you loud and clear, my friend.
It's just such a pleasure to speak to you. I'm
such a big fan of gator mail and plasma and
all your other work plasmas huge right now.
Hey, so I've been pretty upset recently with how
Democrats, Pelosi, Schumer, how they're dealing
with Amy Koney. Barrett. I heard Nancy talk on her
show. Maybe you heard this clip. She said she was
asked by I forget who was CNN and MSNBC, something
she was saying. We have arrows in our quiver to
stop ACB from going through Gill to stop this,
you know, unjust justice from happening. I watched
closely after that to see, you know, we have
heard you talk about on your show, people talk
about other shows like Impeaching Bar, Impeaching
Trump again, holding quorums, forums, any anything
that takes precedence over putting in a bikini. So
I'm wondering what how as a young person in this
coming into this new election, how am I supposed
to have a trust in these Democratic leaders to
tend to hold true to their word, to actually
take action when it counts? Say, I just
can't be the only one feeling just incredibly
disheartened, disheartened and disappointed.
Well, that's that's exactly. This is
it. This is a great question. Basically,
this is why we shouldn't DFI any politician. We
shouldn't believe any politician is going to do
the things they say they're going to do. And there
are people who will strategically apply that. Oh,
Bernie, supporters say Biden won't really do this
stuff. He says or Republicans say, well, Trump
the things that he says he's going to do that
are bad. He's not really a you or whatever.
This is the whole point. We need to just
think about our vote as a tool to try to get
something from our elected officials and to have a
plan to hold them accountable. Democrats blustered
about we might be able to block it this way or
that. Now, in their defense, most Democrats said,
I don't think we have the votes to stop it. That
was that was the reality and that that was true.
But you're absolutely right that everybody wants
to pretend to be all powerful. And in the end,
it's a repetition of the status quo. So we can't
change everything overnight, but all we can do is
who can we vote for that will accomplish something
that moves things in the way we want to see.
And then we make another decision. And as Barack
Obama said, and then you vote again and then you
vote again. But you're completely right. The
defecation of anybody as completely trustworthy
as a politician, whether it's Trump or Biden or
Tootsie or Yang or whoever, you know, that that's
that. No, that's not the way we should be
approaching approaching the political world. And
you you seem to have figured that out astutely.
Oh, great. Well, I have one other quick thing to
add to that. I saw that there is a rule that the
House, the Democratic House or something. There's
some kind of law where two of the members had to
be present for the Senate, preprocessed to even go
through. Yeah, of course. Of course. Mitch just
waived that because, yes, Democrats could have
just chose to not, you know, be complicit at all.
Right. So so, you know, when those when that rule
of law starts getting. I just hope that that we
can find a way to hold these people accountable.
And, you know, there's the Subrata keep
track. There's all these different ways
that we can keep track of all the the minutia
that the TARDIS, the small ways in which
our democracy is being dismantled. So. Yeah.
Well, thank you, David. I really appreciate
you taking the call. I'm a huge fan.
Thank you. So appreciate it. Love the
energy. Great talking to folks. We will go
to a break and we will take calls again,
but it's going to be after the election.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman Datong.